[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom prayer life where we
sift through philosophy to find
practical advice you can use in your
everyday life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm
joined by Michael co-host Dr Greg Sadler
today we're talking about the topic of
rhetoric and the big question that we
have for us is is rhetoric good or bad
and I mean what do you think Dan is it
possible to have like a sweeping
catch all judgment about that it's
either good or it's bad what do you
think
this was over the years that would
avoid the opposing opinion here
um but it kind of
definitely come down to certain maybe
preconceived ideas maybe what is your
definition of the good or the bad here
um but that's kind of another topic and
what you think rhetoric is too right
absolutely
time and so the question is I think the
better is
can you use rhetoric for good or bad so
in this case if you were going to use
like maybe a stoic idea
uh rhetoric isn't a different that it
but it is how one uses it that makes it
good or bad yeah and and I mean there is
definitely a possible bad use of
rhetoric right that we we're all
familiar with people who use language to
manipulate to exploit and stuff like
that and then you know sometimes it is
rhetoric that's being used so
that side is you know we know where
things sit on the outside and then the
question is well how can you use it for
good how can you
persuade people to I don't know things
that they need to do now Aristotle well
I actually say someone somebody we're
going to look at in just a bit that you
need rhetoric
for convincing people to do the things
that they ought to do you know so you
need it in education
you might actually need it if you're a
doctor to get their your patients to
take their medications or to agree to
things that they think are scary so it
can have some positive uses right
yeah but then you know I guess you look
at uh Plato and how he talks about it
and he's like oh
uh
you know if you're teaching then you're
not using rhetoric because if you're
teaching you're going towards the good
of imparting some sort of wisdom and if
you're just giving in the facts then it
shouldn't be why would you even need
some any order of persuasive you know
yeah proportion to that and I think
there's something to that if we if we
take it totally out of the realm of
philosophy and we think about
contemporary
um marketing and product packaging and
advertising and stuff like that so we we
know that the things that we would buy
that we call generic you know store
brand stuff
um it's basically the same product as
the what we think to be higher end
um what do we call these you know like
the good brands right the the name brand
exactly yeah yeah the premium stuff and
so
you know when you look at why the
premium stuff costs way more than the
generic it's in significant part because
of the cost of product packaging which
is a kind of visual rhetoric and then
advertising which is oftentimes visual
but very much uh Speech based right oh
you need to use this kind of ketchup or
you need to use this kind of toilet
paper or you know pick whatever else you
want or you're not gonna you're not
gonna have the same wonderful result
with what you pay for but
um there's a case where whatever we want
to call it communication rhetoric
advertising is making things in some
respects worse for us I mean originally
advertising was just like telling people
stuff it was much more informative and
you'd be like well why is so big exactly
it is well ten times more efficient than
soapy why wouldn't you buy so pay once
you start doing that it's probably
puffery and rhetoric right because how
do you how do you quantify 10 times more
efficient when it comes to soap right
you get 10 times cleaner but in the past
it was more like well this opal get your
body clean you know made from real lie
and and uh whatever else they they
happen to have in it and then people
start yeah there you go then people
started realizing well you can get
people to buy more and more of this if
you start telling stories or in some
cases just outright lying I mean look at
patent medicines you know back in the
the 1800s it was bad enough that they'd
often contain all sorts of things that
you know we now know are bad for your
body because they're they're essentially
hard drugs you know okay good old
Coca-Cola opium right
um with a little bit of you know alcohol
to suspend it all
um but they would make all sorts of wild
wild claims like this is going to cure
everything from lumbago to rheumatism
you know and everything in between well
that's that's that's a use of rhetoric
right there so cure X death
that's yes now that one's a hard claim
to I don't know if you can get people to
buy that
it'll take a course and get them to to
move again
well maybe this one will prevent death
that works yeah because I mean we're
totally like outside of the
philosophical Topic at this point we'll
come back to it but if you think about
when you make claims like that it's
really easy to get people who aren't
paying close attention or don't have
that much on the ball to believe them
because how are they going to know that
it's actually false you know if you take
the stuff and you don't die then the
person who's selling it to you can say
see I told you it's gonna prevent death
and if the person still dies then you
can say well you know he didn't take the
right amount or he was supposed to take
it at night time and he took it in the
morning and see this is what happens we
don't follow the instructions
this is usually referred to as counting
the hits and ignoring the misses oh okay
so this is like a an actual fallacy then
yeah and so I guess um I guess you can
see this with uh a prayer a lot and so
people do this with self-help stuff too
they're like oh I've got this program
for you you just gotta follow the
program and it's going to cost you a
little money by the way but you follow
the program and do it every single day
and you're gonna lose weight or you're
gonna be happy or whatever it's going to
be you're gonna have wonderful
relationships and then when you come
back to them and you're like
hey it didn't work out for me they're
like well did you did you follow the
program you know religiously every
single day and you'd be like well I mean
nobody does uh so no I didn't and then
they'll be able to see that's the
problem you don't get your money back
right
um but going back a little bit too uh
rhetoric and teaching
um we know especially if there's any
teachers among our audience that like
some kids respond better to certain ways
of presenting the information I know
that's true yeah yeah and and see I
would say that you could easily call
this like a form of rhetoric or
presenting the information in different
ways that are you know amenable to these
uh you know the audience that is there
um and that's only with using some sort
of like changing in the ways he
presented either visual or audio or like
making it fun putting into a skit you
know you can look at like uh Jesus he's
got Parables that are trying to import
uh moral ideas
um but it's it's gussied up with a
little story because you remember
stories better than you just remember
when someone tells you a thing
that's true and you know
um again we're off on a little tangent
but I think that's okay because we can
bring it back to the key ideas so what
you're talking about is what people used
to refer to and still do sometimes today
as learning styles right and that was
like a fad in education for a while
there's kinesthetic I'm a kinesthetic
learner I'm a visual learner I'm an oral
learner and then we we found out that
well no things aren't quite
go ahead
it's a little bunk like that didn't find
out there's a lot of data to actually
back up most of this stuff well we found
out that it's not as rigid as it was
being presented it's not like this
person is this kind of learner and
therefore they can only access things
through this modality and that's the way
it was being presented in in educational
formats
um you know as it turns out yeah you're
right there there are people like I
learn things uh quite often better in
chart form and I know that my students
do so I create handouts that put you
know like Plato's argument here into a
chart form and then there's some people
who are better at
um getting things from a text and
there's others who get things better
when it's put into the like form of a
case study right and so so we can do
that
um the idea that it was that everybody
should have to do things the same way
that's clearly wrong the idea that
everybody has like their own little
niche that they fit into and they never
venture out of that Niche that's clearly
wrong too it's somewhere in the middle
right right
uh
sometimes so uh go ahead oh
I was just gonna kind of continue on
here
um so like where where do we start here
with like the full we've already talked
a little bit about Aristotle and Plato
here yeah this is where I guess we kind
of like start this is you know unless
you're gonna go back to the preschool
credits this is kind of like where in
the days of yore
um yeah I mean but but rhetoric could
you tell us a little bit go ahead about
some of the more uh modern people that
we eventually taught you know
oh
um actually I have a prop which uh our
radio listeners won't be able to hear
but we we do this also in video form and
I've got a big thick book here it's one
of my favorite kind Perlman and uh old
brex titekas the new rhetorica treaty
Sun argumentation this is a book that's
that's big and heavy enough that you
could like crack nuts with it if you
wanted to like you know walnuts and
pecans and stuff but it's it's one of my
favorite Works actually and this is by I
got well two people who just spent a ton
of time studying not just rhetoric but
also
legal Theory philosophy literature all
these different connected fields and
then put together a massive I mean how
many pages is this uh 500 plus page
handbook on
um on rhetoric and how argumentation
works and all the different modes of it
I mean the bibliography itself is like
30 pages a lot so that's very
comprehensive
um that that may be a bit of Overkill I
don't think everybody needs to study
rhetoric to that extent although I kind
of geek out about it um and there's lots
of other you know you could say that we
live in a Renaissance of rhetoric
because
in the past it was something that you
studied kind of on its own you know as
its own field and we've had all these
other fields that have developed in in
the 20th century and into the 21st
century like communication study and
communication just to study
communication you're going to run into
rhetoric there or psychology or if
you're
um you know studying English you're
gonna you're sooner or later gonna run
into I mean they actually have one
division called ret comp meaning
rhetoric and composition
if you're in philosophy philosophers for
the most part I would say tend to be
pretty
hostile to rhetoric even today you know
there's there's exceptions we'll talk
about those but
um yeah philosophers tend to be hostile
to it interestingly I remember back when
I was in graduate school and and uh I
was studying philosophy and we had
um you know a lot of people who would
date people from other areas you know
like English or history and one of the
guys who I was friends with was dating a
woman who was studying law and I was so
struck by when we got together at a
concert or something and she you know I
I got introduced to her and she was like
you know what are you studying I said
philosophy and she says oh you're one of
those sophists you know somehow she had
gotten the idea that the philosophy
people were the and if you don't for our
listeners who don't know what selfish is
the sophist is essentially a person who
engages in and maybe teaches rhetoric
and does so for you know for bad reasons
to manipulate people to you know for
greed or you know to to bring about bad
bad outcomes you know they're not doing
it like the doctor convincing his or her
patient that they need to take their
medicine right well either bad outcomes
are just like you know monetary outcomes
yeah do it for money it doesn't matter
you know it's what we usually can
usually uh rail on the law the lawyers
for and that's exactly they just take my
money and then I'll I'll argue your case
it doesn't matter if you did it or not
I'm still going to be you know on your
side and make it so that people think
better of you and so the what you just
said here is is kind of like
mind-blowing that at least the lawyers
are that of of her particular uh
schooling were uh under the
understanding that they were the
philosophers
yeah oh that's interesting yeah I mean
it actually like stopped me in my tracks
and I was like what wait a second you
know you're the you're the people who
are always like you know making the as
they said in ancient times making the
weaker argument look stronger right you
associate that lawyers and here she was
saying that we philosophers do that
routinely I don't know what maybe she
was like a weird outlier or Southern
Illinois University was different than
other places but yeah that was that was
unusual but you know and I think there's
there's a even today there's kind of a
negative pejorative connotation if you
if you talk about something as being
rhetoric like I actually did a a search
on Twitter just to see what would come
up if I put in quotes and rhetoric and
it's all politicians accusing each other
of engaging in rhetoric you know because
it's election season and so saying that
somebody is doing rhetoric is usually
viewed as a bad thing but you know
successful people use rhetoric all the
time including philosophers who claim
that rhetoric is a bad thing and that
they would never use rhetoric they use
rhetoric too
for example uh Plato using the the mouth
of Socrates even in the gorgeous in
which he is a railing against the sofas
yeah
um and then he goes onto this long
diatribe which he had just moments ago
uh said was what the sofas do like
talking at length about something
without actually engaging in debates
yeah or dialogue right yeah yeah yeah I
mean Plato So let's I mean let's talk
about some of this history right so you
brought up Play-Doh Plato is somebody if
you read his dialogues he's usually
criticizing rhetoric right and he does
have some characters who are
rhetoricians you mentioned the gorgeous
gorgeous was a great rhetoric teacher so
successful that he had a statue a
life-size statue of himself made of gold
in his home City out of some of his the
money that he got paid to like teach
people how to speak so clearly he was
quite successful and the dialogue has
gorgeous and polis one of gorgeous's
like uh proteges I guess hanging out in
the house of this guy calacles and
Socrates is there and Socrates first
argues with Gorgeous then he argues with
polis then he argues with the guy whose
house it is which is really kind of a
rude thing to do and
um Socrates is is claiming and this is
you know him being a mouthpiece for
Plato as you said that rhetoric is
irresponsible you know he's he's asking
gorgeous do you make people better
people by teaching them rhetoric and
gorgeous says well I hope so you know
and then Socrates he even says that he
teaches wisdom yeah exactly yeah yeah
and and so you know wisdom with rhetoric
would be like well when do you actually
say these things when is it okay to
trick people
um and gorgeous he has to in the end say
well I guess I don't do that I'm just
really good at teaching people how to
persuade other people you know
um and so please I believe that the
argument like the I guess the Turning of
the argument is like he makes this
assertion that he's teaching wisdom
which is a good yeah and then later on
says but don't you just say that one of
your your students can use this for bad
ends it's like well yes I can it's like
soccer she's like well then you can use
it for bad ends you're not teaching them
wisdom yeah um like I got you I mean
it's it's sort of like today we would
use the metaphor of like putting a
loaded gun into somebody's hand so so
rhetoric is like putting not a crappy
cheap shake it and it falls apart kind
of Old 45 in their hand but like a
really nice new gun with hollow point
ammunition you know you put it into
somebody's hand now they you know if
they want to shoot people they can do it
really really well or if they want to
kill a robber or they want to I don't
know kill a mountain lion that's
threatening people it can be used for
all sorts of things but there's nothing
that guarantees putting that gun into
somebody's hand that they're going to
use it for good
that's that's the big problem you know
so if you've got somebody who's already
a bad person and then you arm them with
rhetoric you're creating
a dangerous situation
I guess this is kind of one of the
reasons why we have such a Negative view
of rhetoric is that we have so many
people in our society that are you know
a lot of politicians usually have ends
that are like you know either increasing
their own power or their own wealth or
both
um and so they'll use rhetoric and
they'll uh to
get to the ends that they want or you
can see this yeah yeah lots of like
cable news that will really pump up hate
and anger and fear um because they know
that doing that gets them more money
it's more than more attention whereas
this actually is not for the betterment
of either the individual nor the society
but they're using that rhetoric in order
to increase theirselves financially yeah
and there's a lot of different
techniques that have developed over the
last couple decades that are they're
based in
um human psychology which hasn't
fundamentally changed and they're based
in if you if you look back at it you can
identify rhetorical techniques being
used
but they're new to us so for example
once we started having the 24-hour news
cycle a lot of the news became not
really news but rather
there is a developing story we're going
to have more details for you later
here's a little bit of speculation about
what it might might be going on we'll
get some news to you in about an hour
from now and it appeals to something
that we've identified in recent years
called fomo fear of missing out right so
you you keep your radio on or you keep
your TV on or something like that and
it's just the same stuff like the next
hour comes by and they're like well we
don't quite know what's going on we know
that there's a developing story here you
know and if you if you tried to pull
that sort of stuff back in say 1970
people would be like well get back to me
when you actually have a story man let
me turn it off but you got you got to
Gussy up and you got to make that a good
old infotainment that's right yeah
breaking down that boundary right and I
guess another portion of that is that
you know the whole idea of it leads to
leads because we are as humans much more
attuned to things that might have a
detrimental effect you know right
something could hurt us or it's going to
be you know bad for our family or our
financial situation we're much more
attuned to that than like the good news
so if you it's like oh no there's uh
breaking news about like a standoff
they've been there for 16 hours but it's
breaking news it's still happening
um and it clicks from that same like
little you know uh Olympic system in the
lower part of the brain stem that's like
oh this is something dangerous and I
need to pay attention to that yeah that
or desire right you can get people
really tuned in if you suggest that
they're going to get something for free
or super cheap or that the people that
they don't like are gonna get hurt
somehow you know
so I mean one of the things we might
want to do is kick around some of there
isn't like a standard definition of
rhetoric I mean you can go to the
dictionaries and they'll give you
definitions but they all vary from each
other and
um there are some good ones that are you
know within the history of of thought so
you know you mentioned
um Plato and the gorgeous he he
characterizes rhetoric in a very
negative way it's a persuasion of
ignorant masses in public settings he
calls it a kind of flattery and he
Compares it to cookery as opposed to
medicine now you know you can actually
cook things healthy Plato doesn't mean
that but that would be more like what
he's calling medicine cookery is where
you use salt and sugar and fat and make
things you know really tasty and
appealing even though they're not good
for you I mean it's basically what a lot
of the big food companies do these days
with processed food and so he views
rhetoric not as an actual art or science
but just as like a whole bunch of
techniques that unscrupulous people use
um Aristotle who's much more receptive
to rhetoric having some sort of role
defines rhetoric and I'm a kind of more
boring way you know it's not quite as
exciting The Faculty of observing in any
given case the available means of
persuasion you know uh maybe if you
unpack that what does that mean the
rhetorician can like look at any given
speech or communication situation and
figure out how to appeal to Their
audience you know what what does it take
to get people to pay attention or or
listen
um Cicero calls rhetoric
um
speech designed to persuade
kind of along the same lines right
quintillion calls it the art of speaking
well
um
one of the negative definitions that
came up in the modern period John Locke
called rhetoric a powerful instrument of
error and deceit but he's committed to a
different idea of you know philosophy
and and speech
um
uh I.E Richards the great
um uh critic said rhetoric is the study
of misunderstandings and their remedies
I kind of like that one you know
and you can now you compare these
against each other right maybe we could
say well
they're all and I don't want to appeal
just to the old thing of the Blind Men
and the Elephant but maybe there's
something kind of like that you know
where like one guy's touching the tail
and he's like oh it's a rope and another
guy touches the the uh uh side of it you
know it's a wall right so maybe these
are
are coming up with different important
aspects of rhetoric it could be used for
bad it could just be
pushing people's buttons like you
mentioned the limbic system right a lot
of rhetoric appeals to that but maybe
it's also something you know like if
Aristotle and Cicero and quintillion are
right maybe it's something that that if
you want to Be an Effective communicator
you need so if if you are one of the
good guys you're communicating important
messages you you have to figure out how
to articulate that message so people can
hear it
that's actually quite good I mean that's
that's an example of of using a metaphor
and transforming it right that's
rhetoric right there so we're doing kind
of meta rhetoric in in uh making up
those funny examples I mean what do you
think about that well I want to go
really back for just a moment
when I asked said like is it good or bad
early on
yeah and so one of the things that
depends here
how you're defining these good or bad in
the first place so
when we're talking about uh
Plato here
Socrates
say making the argument that
the only thing that is has a Taylor sort
of act
that moves towards the good in and of
itself yeah yeah anything else is like
these are things that appeals the senses
but they don't actually always lead to
good yeah they're not good for us like
cooking cookery is gonna make us fat and
sick and you know stuff like that
whereas medicine will
um give us a proper diet that will will
conduce to health right
Aristotle I think starts off the
rhetoric saying that way rhetoric
counterpart to dialectic right putting
it way up higher on the same level as
dialectic whereas Plato's things
totally different than one is entering
towards good and the other one is not on
and and it seems like he's making the
argument of like our faculties here and
that yeah
and rule about ourselves
and that is something you can be learned
and possible I mean there's I mean
there's two things to say in response to
that one is that Plato himself is
clearly a great rhetorician you know
because in in the dialogue Socrates you
know uses all sorts of rhetorical
techniques without saying that he is and
Snookers his interlocutors and Plato
himself is a master of composition right
so there's that side where you're like
well is he really that much against
rhetoric or is he more against like
other people using rhetoric
except sub oh
which is everyone considers to be the
best philosopher in the world anyways
and so you've already go on
the the ethos here oh I'm not gonna put
these
out to someone that you already have a
high reputation about and now he
whatever he says comes out with a
stronger uh horse than just some guy
that's true yeah I mean
Plato himself supposedly was a poet
before he abandons poetry for philosophy
and it's because of Socrates right so
clearly he had some linguistic skills
um and then he meets Socrates he watches
what he does he's he's learning new
techniques from him and how he's uh
handling these these these other people
who are much more committed to just
rhetoric the other thing I was going to
say about Aristotle though so we know
Aristotle is the student of Plato So for
as you pointed out for Aristotle to
elevate rather Rick and say it's like a
counterpart or literally anti-stroke to
to dialectic
um makes it uh an interesting departure
from his his
former teacher right he's he's
um definitely changing things up by
by finding a role for rhetoric
uh
them being a student teacher shows that
it does not mean that uh one's ideas
become only from their Masters
but uh anti-stroke could you define that
oh so it's like a counterpart is is one
way to think about it I mean it comes
from from music right and from poetry so
like you say one line and then the next
line is the anti-stroke to that you know
um and and we should we should also say
what when we mentioned this term
dialectic right and that means a couple
different things so it's not if you're
into like Hegel or Marx or these later
thinkers what Plato and air settlement
by dialectic is not the same thing as
what these later 19th century thinkers
thought dialectic is a
um it's also using language you know the
lectain in it is is speaking and you do
it by like kicking around ideas
Aristotle actually says that dialectic
is what we have to use to figure out the
basic principles and starting points for
all the other disciplines and arts you
know and it provides us with a way of of
getting through things and making sense
of them and
um he he thinks that and you see this
Aristotle doing this in his own Works he
thinks that the where you start from is
not just like going off in your room by
yourself and closing everything off and
then doing pure abstraction you see what
other people had to say about something
um you know famous people people that
you consider wise or smart the ordinary
people and then you kind of sift through
it and you say how much of this is BS
and how much of this is actually
valuable and that's what Aristotle does
in almost every one of his works as a
matter of fact he does that in the
rhetoric too he he says well some people
say this and some people say this and I
think that here's here's the the actual
situation
um that's so that's what dialectic does
and dialectic is aimed at truth whereas
rhetoric is aimed at persuasion
um so they have different you know
different goals but I don't I don't see
them as incompatible you know
there's a lot of
positions right right yeah
so for to continue on what you're saying
it's like we uh we have a really good uh
ability to
come up with ideas yeah we have a really
good idea ability to find holes in other
people's ideas yep
not so great at finding the holes in our
own eye right and that's one of the big
things that dialectic allows us to do is
we present an idea you need to be in a
place where you you know it's okay for
you to
talking and
get good feedback that's not going to
someone whip you down but to get that
feedback that is going
okay
um they pointed a hole out I need to
combine some mortar and patch up that
hole here yeah or make my thing still
work or I need to throw this away and I
need to you know start from
something yeah and I think when you when
you frame it like that I think people
can see that this isn't something that
just philosophers do this is something
like across the board like you could be
in a business meeting and trying to
figure out like how do we
how do we deal with this problem we're
you know we're having some issues that
HR brought up in terms of hiring good
people right and then you know the boss
comes in and says okay we're
brainstorming no bad no bad answers here
right obviously that's not completely
true because if you say something like I
think we should just um
you know walk down the street and like
throw money on the ground
um the boss is probably not going to be
like oh yeah that's that's an
interesting idea they're gonna say come
on shut up and quit wasting our time
who's got a better answer than that
right
um but you know this like you pointed
out the the not having to fear
somebody being just cheerly competitive
with you and jocking for position and
saying stuff to shoot your proposal down
just because it's not their proposal but
you know people coming and giving what
do we call it like you know
um positive feedback uh in the sense of
like useful feedback
because they want you to do better
that's that's dialectic
um
when we get a student paper and we cover
it with red ink and we're like this this
phrase should go here and this should go
there that's kind of like dialectic you
know
yeah
it's a lot of like what is you know
Minds that you're going to go into this
place and hopefully you also have people
that will work with you to actually grow
with you that's the trick is finding the
right people right
um and and maybe you can use
yeah and and I and my personal view I I
kind of go with Aristotle and with
somebody else who are going to talk
about Cicero who think that
um you do need to like know what you're
talking about that's important
um you do need to like try to aim at the
good but you really do need rhetoric in
order to be effective
um if and so let's talk about Cicero
right and some of the other people so
um Cicero has a book called The stoic
paradoxes and he begins the stoic
paradoxes which is about stoicism
um and and paradoxes are things that you
know like are counter-intuitive you
could say we actually did a whole
um and we did we do two uh episodes on
paradoxes or just one episode
uh I'm poor mixed one or two doesn't
matter okay so the stoics had all sorts
of things that they were saying that
other people like that sounds crazy and
these were really important to the
stoics and Cicero said you know you you
stoics are not doing yourselves any
favors by just like throwing these in
people's faces and saying there you go
study it you know learn it and you gotta
like you gotta massage it a bit you
gotta like uh express it in a way that
people can actually connect it so like
one of these paradoxes is all good
things are equal to each other in their
goodness all bad things are equal to
each other their Badness very
counterintuitive right because you can
say if I have 104 degree fever that's a
bad thing that's worse than having a
99.9 degree fever and the stoics are
saying no no they're they're all equally
bad insofar as they're bad so Cicero
begins that work by saying use stoics
you got great ideas but you're really
crap at expressing them and I'm going to
show you how to do it you know what you
ought to be doing and you know he's
doing that in part because he thinks
that good ideas do deserve a hearing and
we have to do that with rhetoric there's
no other way to effectively do that we
could you know we can present things
with just just the facts just the
arguments and that doesn't usually
convince anybody
right well the people in a way that they
will actually take it up
bail on that then you're you're failing
at the sharing that list yeah I mean
you're still gonna have a few people who
read your stuff and they're like oh this
guy's amazing
um but you're not gonna have any broad
social impact you could say and people
like Aristotle and people like Cicero
really did have some massive social
impact because of their their use of
rhetoric
um
and whatever they had to do be it you
know on
design a new bathhouse or you know raise
an army to go and uh
need an innovator yeah yeah like from
the mundane to
most important things of
things session on and you had to sit
there and convince her
go with your brand or at least enough
people to vote for you like you could
get a majority you know
um but you're right yeah that that is
one reason why rhetoric became so
massively important in Ancient Greece
and similarly so in like Republican Rome
you know Cicero himself was a politician
an auditor a lawyer he's using rhetoric
all of the time
um in the later Roman Empire so like if
we're talking about the time when
Augustine is around isn't as a teacher
of rhetoric it's turned into something
that's more like
um
a component of how you teach young
people
how to how to communicate but a lot of
the things that they were using rhetoric
on were stock exercises like come up
with a speech that
um
uh you could have used to seduce Helen
of Trey you know that's not quite the
same thing as like talking to your
fellow citizens and convincing them that
yes we do need to go to war with the
Spartans even though they're scary as
hell you know
something like that
and and I think that you know
um we in in our society right when we
teach rhetoric sometimes we do it in
speech classes sometimes we do it in ret
comp a lot of times the exercises are
pretty artificial we're not really
teaching people how to use rhetoric
effectively whereas you know who is well
you know salesmanship teaching people
how to sell cars or candy bars or
whatever else it happens to be
um another you know
um I mean sales car sales people get a
bad rap and I think rightly so because
some of the time they're lying to you
about you know how great this car is
going to be right
um but we can think about other cases
too like so within the so-called you
know manosphere right there's the pickup
artists who are engaging in what they
call game that's all rhetoric you know
so if you're using a technique like
nagging somebody which I don't think
works really by myself I I can't imagine
it really working but maybe maybe it
does where you denigrate somebody to try
to get them to be interested in you as a
sexual partner that's a bad use of
rhetoric right right and and people
learn it and teach it and charge money
for teaching it
yeah it's kind of just overall sad in my
opinion
um like there might be a certain class
of person that that
little rhetoric
trick might work yeah um but um also
because it's become well known it now it
becomes more people are kind of
inoculated to it they know that's true
yeah and so there's when you were
talking about specifically about the um
who's teaching rhetoric yeah sales
people and if we're not teaching other
people rhetoric then they make some more
easy to be susceptible to these
rhetorical tricks that are used in
everyday life
I mean in other places marketing
departments right or advertising or or
things like that
um
and you know it's interesting too
because when you talk with people in
marketing
some of them are quite concerned about
the ethical implications of what they're
doing in teaching
so you know there's there's some that
have boundaries you could say
um something else I wanted to hit on
though like in this history before we
talk about some of the techniques or
some of the ways of breaking it down so
in in what we call the enlightenment you
know the early modern period to like the
19th century there was this real
tendency to say rhetoric is just a bad
thing and in ways that maybe even went
beyond Plato like you know we mentioned
John Locke earlier rhetoric is just
sophistry and lies you know Renee
Descartes who's also a great rhetorician
he
um he's sort of like Plato he's good at
rhetoric but he he denounces it he says
you know I thought that eloquence is a
gift of the mind
um people who have the most powerful
reasoning and direct their thoughts best
in order to make them clear can always
convince Us best of what they're
proposing even if they only speak the
language of lower Brittany and have
never learned rhetoric now speaking the
language of lower Brittany in France
would be saying like if somebody is the
hillbilliest of the hillbilly delays and
can barely speak you know the language
of the land
um if they're telling the truth they're
going to be convincing now that is a
pretty good piece of rhetoric on
Descartes part because clearly that's
not true but it sounds true doesn't it
yeah well I don't know if it sounds true
to me but like
it's rather eloquent I will do give him
that
yeah so you know there's this tendency
and I think there's still quite a bit of
it today where people are like yeah if
you're doing rhetoric you must be a liar
you must be
tricking people you know but in in the
19th and then 20th century and even
going in into our own time we've had
some just amazing contributions by
people who are recuperating rhetoric and
saying it has to be an important part of
our life and they haven't just been like
going back to Aristotle and Cicero and
quintillion and saying we just like
reduplicate what they're doing they're
adding new stuff as as time goes on
and this is why I wanted to bring up
them the first place okay like this is
not a a dead piece of like thing that
you know was once important but now
really isn't yeah yeah it's languished
and people haven't actually done new
work there's lots of work going on this
and
um not only do we have like you know
writing and speech making as rhetoric
but we have all these new mediums you
can go to
the medium is the message yeah yeah a
basic form of rhetoric you can look at
uh all of our social media even to like
the newest stuff with like Tick Tock and
whatnot really short form videos that
are or memes Are all uh rhetoric in
different ways of presenting the same
thing of trying to convince people of an
idea the truth of an idea
um we can go into Aristotle on that a
little bit later well you know it's I
think that's a great jumping off point
um there is a tendency among some people
to say well I just need to study
Aristotle or I just need to study Cicero
and then I'll know everything I need to
know about rhetoric and they don't
remember that you know Aristotle's you
know he's he's in a different culture
that was
2300 years ago
and there's so much that he didn't
anticipate so he's got some cool
ideas to give us that can be quite
helpful but not everything fits into the
let's say the slots that he he lays out
for us we have to be
um
willing to figure out how does a meme
actually work you know
so and I don't I don't think that
Aristotle is particularly helpful for
memes but he he is helpful for lots of
other stuff
and I feel like it could probably
shoehorn a little bit in there but yeah
it's not okay
okay well I guess the uh the truth
um or not is definitely one of the
uh especially if we're talking about the
legal Summit someone's guilty or not and
so there's uh memes are really really
especially like the the image macro
memes okay really really short form that
has very s
um simple idea that's put forward with
it and I guess I need to bring in uh
Anthony memes which are not actually
related to memes but it's an argument
um that is what Aristotle calls the the
center of rhetoric it is a um usually
what would we call a
deductive argument with at least one of
the premises missing so one of the uh
most well-known arguments is on all men
are of mortal Socrates was a man
therefore Socrates is Mortal but uh
Anthony would be like well yeah Socrates
is a man thus he's mortal like you don't
have to we know the other one
empirically or at least as long as we're
in the same culture we have these same
similar ideas yeah and so the uh
rhetoric is constantly using this thing
where there's a number of bits of
information that you assume your
audience already knows and agrees with
and then you can build off of that and
make conclusions without having to go
through the entire like build out every
single step of I mean it's a deductive
arguments that gets pretty tedious right
right yeah so going back to a meme
there's a lot of subtext that each one
of these assumes that you know before
you even get into the meme and so
there's like you know uh and that's why
some people don't get some of the memes
right because they don't they don't have
the missing bits of information
and and that's that's
politics like especially if you have
like certain if you're on the right or
the left there there are certain
arguments that will resonate more for
the right or the left because they're uh
coming into it with certain preconceived
idea ideas or Notions of the world and
how people react or interact with it you
know for example like one of my favorite
ones to kind of dishonest the the just
World fallacy okay yeah yeah well you
have to explain what that is yeah so the
just World fallacy is that like
um if you work hard and and follow the
rules you're going to get rewarded um
but the world isn't just and you can do
all the right things and you can still
have someone you know beat you down or
destroy your house or or whatever
um just because you happen to be good
and did all what was expect of you
doesn't mean that everything's going to
turn out well
um but if you have that understanding
their expectation then you can build
arguments based off of this just World
fallacy
um that will resonate with other people
that hold the same idea yeah yeah you
know there's another aspect of the
anthem meme that's really I think quite
astute of Aristotle to observe which is
that people like these kinds of things
not just because they want you to cut to
the chase they don't want to be
overwhelmed with too much information
but he says that they like figuring out
the the missing parts
and so there's a certain kind of
curiosity or excitement or enjoyment
that comes with hearing somebody give
them it's almost like part of the puzzle
and then they it's a simple puzzle they
have to figure out the rest of it and so
a really good rhetorician is as
Aristotle says and thematic he he's able
to provide people with just enough to
get them to where he wants them to go
because sometimes you know it is a
matter of like stuff that we all know
and sometimes it's a matter of stuff
that people as they're engaging in their
wishful thinking would really love to be
the truth you know like if you think
about advertising right if you buy this
product
then you know and we show you a little
vignette of like a guy buying the
product let's say it's cologne or
something and then he's got you know a
beautiful woman who's clearly out of his
League hanging on him the implication is
that there's a connection between these
things have to spell it out they just
like show you the picture of it and then
you're like yeah I should go and get
myself some ax body spray or whatever
really happens to me I mean ax did this
thing where they had these guys getting
sprayed with it I don't know if you
remember this advertising campaign and
then women would be chasing them
beautiful women you know and the
implication is well you can be like
these lucky guys too you know and thus
my high school was inundated with ax
body spray it was terrible and I was
teaching college at the time and yes it
was the same problem you could smell it
everywhere
so I was like someone let off like a a
stink bomb but it was like just musty
whatever and there were different uh
varieties of it so they didn't all smell
the same and you put them together and
it's like a it's not a symphony it's
like a a Discord of stink you know yeah
I I wonder if this is how like um
1600s France smelled like when everyone
was just like constantly covered with
very large amounts of perfume because
like because they stank so bad so that's
exactly why you got two different sides
because at least the guys who are
using ax hopefully are taking showers
regularly whereas oh oh you sweet summer
child
so they were they were essentially
taking a perfume bath right is what
you're saying yeah yeah
think of a 13 year old boy
yeah yeah
um but this this uh when you said like
one of the things that makes people
enjoy these arguments is enter memes
yeah yeah
um is people find it kind of like under
sussing out what they're they're trying
to imply and this is
um I would argue a very similar reason
to why we find things jokes humorous
that they are these
partial arguments with portions of them
not uh described and either
um you agree with it and you kind of
like you laugh at the thing yeah yeah
exactly you get it yeah or on the other
way you do it is that you you create an
entity a story that's leading you to one
thing because you've
subtracted one of the the premises and
then at the very end you add one more
premise that totally turns what you are
thinking that unknown premise was to a
totally different premise and the uh
juxtaposition of these two things that
you thought was true and now it's the
other thing makes it funny yeah and
there are some there's like a whole
philosophy of humor out there it's like
a big field and that is one aspect that
some theorists talk about with jokes
it's got to have some sort of twist to
it so some jokes only work like the
first time that you hear them and then
you're in on the joke and it's not it's
not as funny anymore whereas other jokes
you can hear it multiple times and that
twist still works all right yeah but
like one of my favorites is on
um uh why did they say uh signs in front
of escalators as I'm sorry escalators
are broken they should have a sign that
says uh escalator temporarily stares
you're welcome
that is a good one yeah and I've heard
that joke like a hundred times and I
still find it hilarious
you know it works too with visual things
where we like I know especially like
animals we expect to see them doing one
thing and then suddenly they they they
do a totally different thing sometimes
it veers off not into funny but into
cute
right so there could be other modalities
I suppose of it but coming back to the
anthemum yeah Aristotle thinks that this
is really Central to how rhetoric works
but it's it's one main mode of how
rhetoric works and I think we'll
probably just have enough time to talk
about these three modes of persuasion
that Aristotle
highlighted so you know if you Google
Aristotle rhetoric one of the things
that will probably come up is logos
ethos pothos these are Greek terms and
what we've been talking about with like
the enthamine that's logos or argument
um logical presentation of things and
and you can convince people using that
you know you you can make an argument
but um we also talked a little bit about
um keying into people's emotions well
that's pothos so Aristotle says that you
know people see the world and their
situation differently depending on what
they're feeling so if you can actually
make people angry
and direct their anger at the things
that you want you can get them to do
certain things if you instead want to
make them fearful then you have to know
how to provoke fear you know or Envy or
emulation or love or hate or any of
these other emotions now some of them
are more effective than others you know
um just making people sad
doesn't really motivate them to action
quite as well even if it's like those
Infamous
um uh is a Humane Society stuff that had
uh Sarah McLachlan and it would show
like the horribly abused animals with a
you know sappy Sarah McLaughlin
sawing behind it
um whenever that comes on my my wife
actually turns it off because it tugs at
her heartstrings mine too but hers more
than mine
um sadness doesn't motivate people that
well but desire fear anger all these
things they sure do you know to go back
to like body spray you can get people to
buy deodorant if you suggest to them
that nobody's going to like them if they
stink that's that's fear right so so
that's another important aspect and then
we have what's called ethos meaning
character and you mentioned that earlier
right with with Socrates Plato using
Socrates as a mouthpiece so you know
what kind of person you present yourself
as being
that is
um that's that dimension of ethos and
Aristotle actually tells us and he might
be wrong about this but I think this is
a kind of a good guide uh guideline that
there's three important features we want
to see that people are actually good
people they're virtuous we want to see
that they have practical wisdom they
know what they're talking about they
they understand how things work and then
he talks about Goodwill and he says that
if you really want to be convincing you
have to get the audience to think that
you aren't just a good person and have
something to contribute but that you
care about them
you want the best for them
and if you don't have that
you're you're not going to be as
convincing
right
if you just think that they're out for
themselves and like oh yeah do this
because I'm gonna make money then I'm
like exactly yeah yeah
why don't why should I care about that
guy I mean it's interesting you think
about multi-level marketing and I
realize we're getting really close on
time so I'll keep this super super short
you know in multi-level marketing you're
making money on people who are below you
in the organization you have to convince
them that it's a good thing for them to
be paying out some of their money to you
and the way that you do that is by like
having them at parties and saying hey
we're all in this together and you know
stuff that's clearly false right so uh
PSA on multi-level marketing is a
pyramid scheme don't do it
so
um I guess we leave you here today with
the words of Aristotle what makes a
person a sophist is not his faculty but
their moral choice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]